that's interesting so that's
referring to more that there should be a
consistent habit
versus uh the total amount to me like
the entirety of the picture of sleep
is uh it's similar to nutrition in that
it feels like it's
there's so many variables involved and
it's so person specific
so you know a lot of studies i mean this
is the way of science
has to look in aggregate the effects on
sleep it doesn't focus on high
performers
and which are individuals ultimately
like
the question isn't uh so it's a very
important question it's like what kind
of diet
fights obesity reduces obesity
it's another question what kind of diet
allows david goggins to be the best
version of himself so
these high performers in different
avenues and the same thing with sleep
like
people that tell me that i should get
eight hours of sleep
it's like it it's i
i mean i i get it and they may be right
but they may be very wrong
there's no evidence that eight is better
than six
that you could very well do better on
six than on eight there are a few other
things that
um turn out to be strong parameters for
success in this domain for instance
your entire life waking or sleep is
broken up into these 90-minute ultradian
cycles if you look at ability to attend
or do math problems or do anything
you know drive performance tends to
ramp up slowly within a 90-minute cycle
peak and then come down
at the end of that 90 minute cycle and
in sleep we go through these
stage one two three four rem etc we'll
talk more about that if you like those
on 90 minute ultraidian cycles as well
ending your sleep after a 90 minute
cycle at the at the
near the end of a 90-minute cycle say at
the end of six hours
in many cases is better for you than
sleeping an additional hour seven hours
and waking up in the middle of an
altradian cycle
and there are a few apps that can
measure this based on body movements and
things like that that
have you your alarm go off at the end of
an ultraviolet cycle
and if you wake up in the middle of an
altradian cycle sometimes not always you
can be very groggy for a long period of
time
i certainly do better on six hours than
i do on seven
i happen to like an eight hour sleep it
feels great
but i haven't slept an entire eight
hours without waking up in the middle of
the night at some point in
i don't know forever i can't remember
it's probably some point in
infancy but
you